hello everybody
welcome to another night of chess on
psychology
hope you are having a great time i
apologize for this small delay
there was a small issue with lycha's
study so i had to
make the little difference um and
transfer our games
to lita to actual chess base i've always
been a chess base girl i don't know why
well i mean i know why i like started to
really like leeches so i've been doing
it on leaches
as in past few months i intend to go
back only just as soon as they've
debugged it
so um yeah let's go ahead and get
started let me make sure i have
my chats ready from the ipad 2 because
i want to be able to talk to you guys to
the best of my abilities
a little heads up as well gmp she's
having a little visitor behind the door
for those of you who are keeping score
now i am feeding three stray cats and a
real cat and two possums
so it's like a weird party over here i
it's like i when i once i start feeding
them i can't stop
they keep coming back they're so cute i
can't it's just i can't
i can't not uh not feed them
they're way too cute i kind of started
naming one or two of them too but it's
cute they come back behind the window
the meow i opened the door i feed them
they hang out
they me out for peachy peachy meows for
that it's a whole situation
uh yeah so it's a lot of
the cat stuff going on um so let's go
ahead and get started the first game
that we are looking at is surprisingly
not
um well it is it's the it's a really
good game it was
okay to be honest uh jordan or you're
then winning
the tata still was a huge surprise to me
i did not expect it
i did not have my money on him well i
didn't really bet on anybody
about it but just in the conversations
he was not
expected to win so it was a very very
interesting situation
i've known him since he was i can't say
yeah
because he was always taller and he's
i don't know what's with the dutch
they're always so tall but we have two
um
two of the dutch players on our team
here in san luis university and
they're all so tall i actually look up
like that my neck hurts
but yeah benjamin buck and uh robbie
uh oh god please let me pronounce the
strength
kevlish really hopefully i said it right
if not he can tell me himself but yeah
they're both super cute
super nice but um yeah extremely tall
like my necklace i don't know it wasn't
a dutch water
but let's go ahead so this is a game
between
uh jordan who huge congratulations
whether
it's a huge honor i can't even imagine
what
you feel it's it's a i can't it's a
huge congratulations to him and this was
a game that he played against
uh grandinious nils and um
the it was it was a very good game i
really enjoyed it
um so let's go ahead and get started i
am looking at the chat so i see a lot of
suggestions about having a cat gambit
hey no no no peachy gambits let's let's
get our copyright straight
um so okay let's go ahead
uh the first game was i tend to show
two it might be a little different than
um intended okay
um so i
really like this game because i first of
all play evora's wide so i didn't have
to go through all the hoops and
trying to uh enjoy the position looking
at
from like nothing that i don't play i
play this opening it very much liked
this opening
and the fun part was this idea with
queen d3 because i played this
i want to say 20 like 15 a bunch i still
play this queen d3 with a different
um little different variation especially
with like
bishops out already but like this idea
of queen d3 i play and i
absolutely love that jordan or igor then
played this it was amazing
so um all right i want to take a little
quick
idea of um what do you guys think about
so
what do you think like how is this
position gonna go is this gonna be
one of those positions that white's
gonna try
and um play the king side queensland
center just like a
super quick idea to just get the feeling
of the position
i am pushing him thank you for noticing
yeah you know i've also noticed
a lot of the perch a lot of the people
who guess i'm middle eastern or hershey
and have
kind of go with by the eyebrows i don't
know what is it but i do get a lot of
compliments on my eyebrows
very proud of them worked very hard on
them
yeah gotta send some thanks to my
parents for the eyebrows too
um i wish i could say the same with
peachy because she has literally like
two hairs coming out of his eyebrows um
all right so let's go
um
so what do you guys think
all right i see so i set some questions
about what
is the idea with queen d3 i agree that's
why i'm bringing it up because i want to
know what you think
uh so the thing with queen d3 is that
when i play a lot of the times this
queen on d3 it kind of depends on how
opponent plays it
but could have a lot of benefits going
on the king
side so that's one another one is
that there is this like really cool
ideas well
black didn't do this but let's say if
black played e5
you would do knights b3 let's say bishop
out you just get your bishops out and
now this is
this is some type of positions that i
play or let's say castle
um castle let's say you get your knights
out now there is this cool knight d5
idea
and you kind of have to take it because
if you don't
next c4 a4 a5 all of these are coming
and fun thing is you can't take it to
the knight because now your bishop
is kind of stuck so you have to take it
to the bishop
so white immediately gets two bishop
advantage this bishop is super cool
there are a lot of pawn ideas coming up
so white scheme is somewhat in the like
both
kingside clean side black ends up having
some cool ideas in the
king side as well but it's like a whole
different world i have shown few games
of mine and this
i intend to talk more about it next week
um there are going to be some changes
make sure to keep your eyes out on the
schedule
and the calendar uh oh
we have a romeo romeo situation going on
here with the cats
anyways um so
that's kind of one of the things to keep
in mind
about this type of queen d3 but i agree
queen d3 is kind of weird
uh in the game nails played knight d7
uh jordan got his bishops out and this
b5 was a little
too early again this is all theory uh
there are different
ways of playing this they're different
ways trying to play with eva
trying to go to e6 to getting your
knight out i'm playing d5 part so
there are many different ways but this
b5 um
it's not exactly the first thing you
think about when you're playing queen d3
so all right
i'm reading the chat all right as i
think the cats are trying to have their
own type of valentine going on
ah makes more sense that that's why
there's so many stray cats coming are
the suitors or peachy
a peachy is male so is pushing this
situation
being chased by all these cats
wow huh i never knew all these things
i'm kidding hopefully nobody is chasing
my cat i like my cats
all right so this idea with a4 let's try
to
get through the opening it was a very
beautiful game and it wasn't
actually that's long um i
intended to show another game i think
one of the games that
um jordan played with
geary one of them was expect they're all
really great but one of them was
extremely
long and i did want to show that but if
i showed that then i wouldn't have the
chance to talk about any other game and
i don't know how
um how up to date you guys are
with the whole stuff in um
in tata still but there was like a
little drama going on
something about an arbiter or like the
rules that uh
made elliot distracted and uh there are
a lot of like little things so i do want
to talk a little about that too so i
want to get to this game so we can talk
a little bit of gossips
my days are boring all in library and
just
same studying and same food and same cat
stuff so i like gossiping so let's go
let's try to get through this so we get
through a little bit of fun
tournament gossip um yes a4 is
that is true he wants to play uh he
wants you to push e4 because if you push
b4
now i get to try and this is a weakness
i can go around and start poking it
or as this was another game that i
believe monica soko played
that's another idea to just try to
develop a different
way as well but um just
this is like a little nice idea to try
and start poking at
or if you get the chance play a pilot
and leave it isolated
so in the game niels played knight c5
which
was a novelty and i it's been a while
since i've
analyzed this position to play as white
so
this definitely is new to me but it's
good to know that this is
like a real novelty not just a novel to
my eyes
um queen e3 was played which makes sense
right you gotta try and defend your pawn
because well if you don't ideally this
queen wants to try
and whoops not go there try to be in the
uh king side and not to block my own
bishop
but the problem is the queen of steel he
takes it right
queen g3 e4 falls queen f3 their bishop
b7s
is i don't really want to have to deal
with those
so um it's too early to try and give
black that much game
so um there you have it also let me
relocate my t so i don't have to
click back and forth like crazy
all right so knight c5 queen e3 makes
sense
not the exact ideal position for white's
queen
but i will get there um
yeah before ninety five take
and in this position a5 was played
i was under the assumption that knight
b4 was the way to go but i can
understand why this wouldn't exactly be
as desirable especially because now um
well you have the castle and there's g6
and you're still like unsure what you
want to do with this bishop
it leads to more complications and
i believe um you are some yes your car x
i have i've never really had the bad
experiences with arbiters or tournament
directors
i mean they're always minor hiccups but
nothing that's i would be like yeah that
tournament this happened that happened
but it was so funny because um eve like
before i came to saint louis i remember
this was like in 2015 because i was
playing ward use in greece
um there was like all these um
talks about how best we saw roads
on his uh scoresheet sometimes like
encouragement wars but that was against
the rules so
he he lost the game which was by law
within the arbiter's right
i was kind of funny because i used to do
that i used to like
write a little encouragement things on
my score sheets
before the game and um it was funny
because when i was in
the world youth championship in greece
the arbiter gave me like a mini warning
like hey
by the way you shouldn't do this
remember that big case how wesley's so
locked so i was like yeah okay
so yes um they're always going to be
laws that we're just going like what
but it's in life so that's not just the
chest
anyways um let's go ahead
and continue with our game
the winner of the tournament i'm really
loving this a5 it like
makes a boat of these pawns super
isolated
and the fun part about it is now black
has a choice
you kind of have to take on d5 because
if you don't now this will fall there's
a bunch of knight b6 coming up so you do
have to take
and now that's the real problem for
black because wha white's queen is
centered even though white has given up
a pawn
it's not exactly um ideal situation
for black because all the these pawns
are weak
um white has a better um
better space better piece development
why it's only one move away from
castling
so black simply played e6 bishop b7 was
also desirable but the main problem with
bishop b7
was that it would make it more
complicated
castle queen c8 and now white's kind of
just developing and getting the pieces
out
when black is still trying to figure out
okay what should i do with this bishop
how can i ever castle
and it's not exactly i wouldn't want to
play this position as black it's too
um too pressuring
uh forcing your client to create and
yeah yeah
you're right yeah um trying to open up a
little bit
on the queen side and trying to poke
around with the pawns is always fun
now uh question let's say we castle
bishop bishop d7 now
how should white continue i'm gonna give
you guys about a minute because
um i really want to be able to get some
of your ideas on how you think
this position should continue you know
white has a little bit better space
but um better with better piece
positioning but the problem is that this
position is so
dynamic it's not like you have to know
what you're doing and you can't just
play like f4 or five
you have to actually know what you're
doing you can't just like
in farsi if you have an expression for
my
uh persian speaking viewers like that
like let me try and translate which is
like
picking up a slipper and running i don't
know if that
makes much sense to non-farsi speakers
but yeah that's something that um i grew
up with the expression that like
if you want to attack what you don't
really know how to when you just start
attacking
that's like that expression i like
picking up a slipper and running
the slipper is supposed to be used as a
weapon
which i don't know how terrifying that
is
it doesn't really scare me but
anyways um so let's see there's some
ideas oh we can
ask s4 bishop f3 my friends you are a
little too brave for my taste
um and you are then simply to continue
to develop just get your bishop out
what else are you going to do with this
bishop you got to get it out
bishop e7 now the suggestion of
bishop f3 that was so let's see bishop f
street now
you're just simply putting your pieces
in better positions it doesn't need to
be such a big deal
um so yes you are also
to be fair i considered bishop theater
to be also quite interesting because you
just kind of
stopped the ideas with castle um but
it's not like i mean you don't exactly
stop it worst case scenario there's
always going to be like a knight of six
and then you would have to move this
queen somewhere why actually queen is
trying to really like it
uh let's say you would have to move this
queen somewhere oh there's a queen
interesting um and there's a rook beat
they're still like there's still a lot
of stuff going on but my point being
i i thought bishop d3 was interesting
but
you are don't play bishop f3 since he
won the tournament
i can't really go against him if he
didn't win i would definitely
not kidding i i'm going to talk about
what the position needs
um all right so bishop f3
black played castle that was mine like
that was my tiny problem that is why i
wanted to play bishop d3 but
jordan had a different idea he continued
with bitcoin d3
following it by pushing this c pawn
which was super cool cool because i had
thought of it
um c4 take and then he took with the
pawn
which was again quite interesting
because you usually try to be like yeah
i'm not gonna have an isolated pawn
and in this specific game jordan
actually
went for it and he wanted to have that
and
especially because there is still one
less pawn on the board
i wasn't exactly um i wasn't exactly
sure what was going on i know that white
is
still doing fine but
to what extent was the question
yeah yourself yes that is highly likely
i am not going to agree with that
um so anyways uh
in the game backed by drook a7 honestly
i doubt that both players had already
prepared to this extent
it is possible that they both knew bike
about the middle games of this hello jmp
sheep uh-oh we got a cat coming incoming
cats
i gotta move the microphone because the
last time kishi brushed against
the microphone i believe one of our
moderators had
ear issues going on for a while
all right you gotta go back
all right it's good for you so ah i
managed to
not um hurt people's ears yay
yes i got i got pc
he actually jumped up there surprisingly
um in the there was a suggestion of
bishop f6 which i do agree bishop f6
is quite interesting it's um
it makes the uh mixed black pieces look
just a tiny bit better all right let me
move the microphone back where it was
hopefully i did
not touch it in a hurtful way
um
put that situ on yeah i i agree that
situation can be extremely
useful but it's also a little yes
exactly it also gives some weaknesses
vibes but i guess that's the price we
have to pay
if we want to have peace activity if you
want to have open rooks we have to have
some little weaknesses now
quick question guys let's say now we
played this c4
you moved your night now why to do what
uh what to what to do it's a very
beautiful move
um do i think it's beneficial to play
against a computer
continuously um
depends because i have some students who
love playing against computer
but the problem is that they don't
choose the
their own level they like to win so they
choose like lower levels and i don't
i don't agree with that that's just like
i don't like how
some of the computer bots don't take
like you take their piece and they just
look at you they move something and so
i'm like no
take everybody takes back so
yeah no like i
i like winning but i feel like the
winning should be something
a little bit more than just winning i
want to learn something i don't want to
blunder all the time and know that my
opponent is not going to take that's not
real
all right um
bonora chess good job thank you
and i know that some of you might have
seen this some of you might not have if
you have seen it
um feel free to ta the class for me i
love that
if you have not seen it however and you
consider the move knight b5 that is
going to be
like a wow because when i was looking at
this i thought man it would be nice if i
had knight b5 maybe i should play like a
bishop e3 to prepare for it
but jordan knows best well in this game
let's go with that
and he went for a knight b5 and i was
just like
so take take and now um
black realized that these two pawns are
very monstrous when you pair them up
with this bishop and the other bishop
coming up
and if white gets some b6 and a6 those
bombs are pretty unstoppable
there's a nice song that's sia
had unstoppable i've been listening to
way too much
music when i study anyways so
black took bishop to hb5 we gotta take
that back
um now bishop e3 is coming up too so how
can black stop bishop e3
uh what happens if black didn't accept
the sacrifice well
it wasn't exactly a sacrifice more as
like more of an exchange like i give my
knight for this pawn and this bishop
and you take my knights at this pond
because if you didn't accept it the rook
is falling so you kind of have to take
it
oh paul that's so amazing yeah no
i believe um no we have two dutch and
our team here in san luis university
win the third one i don't know how to
translate that expression if there are
any farsi speakers here and you want to
help me translate
tosena please help me because i tried to
explain that to another friend of mine
recently and i just
failed and it was just like super weird
to try and explain that so
yes um you see this knight is
uh very crucial in the sense that this
knight needs to come covered
up a little bit in the queen side so
knight d7
and boom bishop b7 queen has to move
queen c7
was a better choice but queen d8
is um also doable you gotta move
something with your queen
so um
[Music]
queen d8 boom a6 now what is the idea
we are simply trying to play a quick
a cute little bishop cute little bishop
e3 try to eat the stroke sooner or later
now black played bishop f6 boom bishop
a5
now you got to move the queen bishop c7
this position is just so beautiful
and the idea of bishop's seven like this
bishop is staring at your rook and all
you're saying is
nah man i don't need this rook come take
it
and um the bishop v1 was actually the
best move there's not much else for
black to do
and the fun thing is like this rook is
just like
acting like a pawn just stopping this
pawn it is so weird
i really do like this um
this game it's one of the most beautiful
ones i've seen
so far
yes so in the game black played d5
to be fair uh d5 was a bad move the best
but was knight c5
which would try to cover up a little bit
maybe get some queens to exchange
try to eat some of these pizzas try to
make it a little bit more
hard for whites to just come and
um have an easy game so now can you guys
tell me why
d5 is a bad move
that is a huge mug i agree you see the
problem is that yesterday i didn't
finish the things i wanted to study
so i was doing flash cards and beds from
like two to four
i managed to do like about 300 of it but
it also meant that i slept at 4 4 30
so and i had to be up at 9 30 for my
pharmacology class
so yeah i need a big mug
i like it because it's all golden i
initially got this one as like a
prison for my mom because it was like
like such a
um cool mug and my mom is a huge
coffee slash tea drinker she
she he's being all playful
all right i see some really cool ideas
are coming in bishop d6 it is good job
you guys bishop d6 simple
i'm gonna poke your [ __ ] i'm gonna poke
your rook
as well as i'm just opening with my
bishop nothing wrong with that
trying to just put more pressure on you
a lot of the time pressure
is an amazing um
thing you don't necessarily need to
actually find a checkmate
but a lot of the times just pressure and
threatening is
extremely strong so in the game
black played queen d8 now simply rook c1
i just want to take over here go play
rook c8
and this is going to be fun
so in the game black made another
mistake and played the g6
the better move would have been rook e8
just trying to avoid
rook c8s and if you play it like rook c7
not knight v8 i understand
this is a quite sad and just
just oh my god i don't want to look at
this position for black
let's take a quick look oh my god look
how
black is just like all tied up in one
side and when you
flip it back to looking at this position
from white
it's like so much space i know fishy i
agree with you
so much space so yes
now let's go back to position now let's
say black played this g6 which was a
mistake now what would you do
is it time to try and eat over here
should we try to
get some action going on at any time
yeah i also have cat ears all over my
face because
i was in the library right before i came
back to my room like 10 minutes maybe 15
minutes before
the stream and as soon as i came back
pishi was meowing and he needed the hug
because i was out for
five whole hours oh my god so when i
hugged him i have cat hairs all over my
face which does not help it
because yeah cat hairs doesn't really go
well with
eyes and ears well actually you should
be fine eyes and nose
so
okay yara's love interesting you uh you
you see that queen g5s could be a
potential
um issue so you go for h3
good i love it yeah this truck isn't
going anywhere
and well to me fair taking is completely
possible
but my issue is that well first of all
this queen g5s don't really exactly work
but um my issue is a little bit
more with well then what it's possible
nothing against it
but uh i don't exactly
like having to deal with let's say
knight takes f8
rook c8 and now let's say can i just go
to maybe
g5 no let's go to f6 yeah try to go over
here
yeah and not exactly i don't want to
give black hopes i want black to stay
all tied up so white plays h3
awesome rookie 8 boom rook c7
that's not such a cool idea now why
black made another mistake or maybe more
of an inaccuracy and he played
knight f6 and knight b8 was supposedly a
little bit better
now if queen if russia ate not take a
take
and uh white could um still have
some trouble winning this not that it's
going to be too hard but at least
black has a better fight going on um
i guess we could actually take it over
here now if you're hurricane
wait wait why am i playing your k6 take
take yeah i mean it's good it could put
up some more
pressure but anyways this position feels
too
hopeless
h3 is like just a good idea to try
and prevent whoa hello bishi any ideas
that
um oh he's coming for the microphone
kitty he is being hyper
all right um where was i yes
talking about the difference between h2
and rook c7 first honestly
h3 just makes a little bit more sense
because ideally
if your opponent allowed you you want to
be able to play rook c8
you want to take on f8 play rook c8
so you know pc is a little too happy
that i'm home
he's like he's so cute in the sense that
whenever i come back
from outside anytime more than like 10
minutes of me being outside i come back
he he comes greeting me meow meow where
have you been
why are you so late i've been alone all
day and he has food and water and
everything but he
still meows and comes to greet it's
super cute
why are sicilians better than rook c8
well in this specific position it is
because rookie 8 was played if there was
no rookie i believe
we would take it as over here and then
play rook c8
so
rey lopez i have no
children at the moment or for
foreseeable future
the the best i can do right now as a cat
the fluffier the better
yes so all right i'm glad everybody
agrees on how cute
she is now rookie anthony talked about
rook c7
and we also mentioned the idea with
knight f6 now quick question
what should we do again you know that
white is
much better and you know how beautifully
this position is organized and all you
have to do
is try and well
not mess it up so how can you do that
what was the question uh why to move
what to do
careful careful this queen d6 exists
let me make sure i am
yeah still
online still going on yeah cats are
great
they're also quite distracted you're so
cute
they can distract you with their
cuteness okay good
thank you bishop e5 it is i saw other
suggestions
but um bishop e5 is the most logical one
simply i just want to eat on f6 eat on
e8 a lot of eating
uh black plate knight e4 boom queen c6
and next move let's just
rock d7 also looks pretty cool whoa
percy eight looks pretty cool let's see
what else looks pretty cool
oh if i could even consider something
with bishop d4 to eat your rook
so there's so many different options
i like queen c6 because you see
the queen c6 you're clean right now
could be improved so let's improve it
you get this recall hyped up in the game
uh black played rook f8
which i believe was to avoid this idea
with rook c8 because if you played rook
c8 now this guy is a little in the
pickle
so rook f8
bishop d4 as i was previously mentioning
on some of the ideas that queen c6
could help with um black white queen b8
now why to move water this was also
um this to me was like a weird move
because i know i'm better well
i know it's white and better but i
didn't exactly know what
move to play
nope come on guys we can do better
whoa nice f3 great job everybody
so after f3 black takes rook takes a6
now let's see what should we do
should we take this with the bishop
should we take it to the queen
any any differences alicia's studies is
still down
i tried i really did want to make
transition to leeches but
so to be fair bishop a7 is possible but
a fish of a7 queen a7 how do you plan to
get this queen away
and also keep keep in mind this f2 is
weak
so you might have to like come back to
defend your f2 it's not going to be
it kind of messes with your um
harmony so f3
rk6 all right let's take exactly thank
you yaroslav
bishop a6 because if 0.96 queen c7 and
your advantage is going bye-bye
actually black had advantage in that
position so visual basics
white blacklight queen before now keep
in mind
you still have you have a you have more
material
but you still have to be quite careful
on how you
play the next moves so bite to move how
do you intend to continue
i guess the main question is should we
take this knight
or should we come up with a little
smarter idea
bishop e5 good job thank you yourself
uh this is possible and it's just a
little weaker because it cleaned before
and then
is another check and yeah you don't want
to have to deal with that
i mean i guess there are ways to try and
play king h1 but
this also brings up the other issue of
queen a1 because if queen c1 boom
if king h2 again check so not much way
to run away from
so let's just play our bishop e5 you
give me check
king h2 you're out of checks my friend
knight f2
you want to go queen h1 how should we
continue how can we try to
eliminate some of what black is trying
to do
is growing
so a lot of the things in this
tournament was really great because
first of all there were so
many younger players which
made the tournament even more
interesting because not
not many of these young players get the
chance to
play the big boys so that was pretty
cool
i didn't particularly enjoy
some of the games but i'm not the
biggest fan of draws
but i can't help it no one can so a lot
of the times if the both players play
good the game is going to be drawn
nothing wrong with that just
doesn't make me particularly happy but
um whoa careful bishop g3 that's gonna
be a fun checkmate for him
so let's bring queen c3 we have extra
material so let's try to exchange some
of it off
if we don't we can also consider trying
to like bishop the shade
and like queen g7 in the game uh
black played check and then queen g1
trying to
create more checks now what should we do
wait wait wait wait yeah islam you've
seen this game
wait wait wait no i thought you were
finding the moves from hearts i was so
proud
it's okay when you love chess too much
you
will be uh there will be a lot of games
that you've already seen
so ah yeah
queen c1 um
i think we should go for something a
little bit more spicy
which i will say it is interesting but
keep in mind this check is coming up
it's not going to bother us too much
because we
still have king h4 but let's try to have
like something with a threat
no pt
i kind of like this idea of rook c8
keeps things simple i wanted to give you
checkmates
checking up check g3 you're done
checking me my friend
well actually there's one more check and
then there's one more check
and it was kind of interesting because
the king got to go all the way up i love
this game
um so
in the game white uh
had to deal with f takes e5 now how do
we continue after f takes e5
keep in mind this king is super weak and
all we need
to win is just a little bit more
checks
how do we get
the job done
uh are there some sound issues because
if there are please let me know
gmp is grooming himself
queen c7 uh possibly but queen e5 makes
the most sense
i'm just going after one check here two
chick here
[Music]
leave me a three check here a bunch of
different checkmates queen e5 good job
everybody
and actually uh niels resigned in this
position so that was a pretty cool game
i thought this was jordan's best game in
this tournament
if i had to pick a best game of the
tournament this would probably be it
there were there were many other great
games too
but come on there's a king on h6
so if i had to choose this would at
least be on top three might be a very
close call
but there's some of the games that had
so many great potentials but people just
didn't find them
but anyways this was a great game um
[Music]
alright yes i hope you guys enjoyed this
game
huge congratulations to jordan uh let's
go ahead
oh hold on i have to
reload the next one there wasn't there
was another game that i absolutely
enjoyed too
but i won't be having enough time to
show it unfortunately i do intend to
talk
more about some of these games on our
future
future classes tuned i need a second to
switch the board oh it didn't change it
much yay
all right so uh this was another amazing
game of the tournaments this game was
played between
alireza and watched isaac
and um i believe this was
in one of the playoffs uh the rules
confused
me a little bit so if any of you
are more confident on exactly
what happened on the rules and
what went wrong please feel free to
enlighten the chat
because i read through it i watched
some of the videos on it but i still
confused
so um this is like a position that i
wanted to
show because i thought this is a pretty
cool position so
uh this is after 25
six moves so i want to get a quick
evaluation on what do you guys think
about this position
i'll give you a little heads up that's
uh
white it's tiny bits better
but uh there isn't much to do but
like i want an actual evaluation i don't
want just who's better i want why of it
whose king is better whose center is
better whose pieces are better
who has more stuff going on
um there were some issues on
this um there are some little gossips
well not gossips
i call them gossips because to me
they're gospels but they're quite
painful for the players
um so there were like a thing about the
tiebreak
because the players had to
play um it was like too many of them
that that the same
same same score so they had to play each
other
and the winner of those would like play
like would be the winner
but um the problem was that when elijah
was praying washtasik
and um
jordan was playing geary uh well your
number had already
was kind of clear his tiebreak was
better but
this was a kind of crucial game for eli
reza because
he's um
yeah oh thank you for the far state
explanation too
so yeah apparently there was um
like they wanted to there was i could
think about changing the table
which i it it doesn't make that much
sense to me
on like why the organizers were
hoping that this would be like brilliant
idea
but again in a high tension it's a
little weird to try and
yeah there was a yes thank you yeah
i i see the chat is making more
statements
and much better than i am doing so
yes yeah up yes
exactly so um let me try to translate
that apparently there was a lot of noise
so there's a
um requested that they would be uh that
the request drink requested that the
ruby silence he wants to play
and he did have advantage in this game
that was the crucial game and then
uh they as a as a result of his
complaint of hey there's too much of
noise they
told him to change the table which is
i mean i've done that before in some
tournaments but
not exactly my favorite thing to do when
you're playing chess and when you're all
focused
i don't even want my cat in the room so
all right yes back to the chest of it i
see
that you guys agree why it's a little
bit better
and i also see that um
there are some ideas with bishop h5
checks there's some ideas
with okay i agree yes
um so white is a tiny bit better i agree
but black still has lots of game going
on so i'm gonna
fast forward a little bit to um
just a few moves king f7 getting the
center
and this is another position that i
wanted to talk about
now now what do you think white should
do white has these two
bishops why it has the central ponds
what has a little bit
better peace developments but how should
we continue
um ray lopez that's not a very common
thing to do
there on specific circumstances that is
possible
um
yes yes i agree fragrance that's that
does cause disturbance
and i i also saw that there was an
official like letter of apology from the
organizers to
i don't know if those exact organizers
was from because of that situation to
ali reza they officially apologized to
him
for pausing the um
disruption but yeah so i thought that
was a pretty cool gossip not for alireza
or
anyone involved in that situation but
for a
observer and for me to talk about it
later and tell my friends about
hey guys this crazy thing happened in
the chess world
i like that idea i don't really get too
many crazy
things happening in chess world that i
can tell my friends about
so school friends about
yes exquisite i i hear you
all right um so after rook t8
i see all right so i see some of you
might have seen these games if not
nothing wrong with it you can always go
back and look at them there are on the
official websites they're
on test.com chess space just 24 do you
say
chess they're gonna have analysis of
these games uh that's not i don't intend
to spend too much time on this
tournament
because everybody in the chess world is
analyzing it but
i do pick some of my favorites and i do
talk about them
um
so our royal opposite ray lopez the
saying why should exchange the white
bishop yep
yes i do like to make all of my
non-chess
friends go chess world is wild
so what are the weak points
of black here well
i would say this bishop isn't doing that
pretty
this knight is looking good but i don't
know how useful this will be in the long
run
the main problem that black has is
what he what is supposed to do in in
future
there could be some ideas with like
trying to play c5 but
the white has two bishops so that might
even end up helping white
so in the game white played h4 those of
you who suggested the new h4
were correct that's funny p
p d black knight looks silly i i kind of
agree i mean it's
a nice looking knight but i don't know
what he wants to do to it
so after h4 v6 bishop e2 was played
which i found
quite interesting because you're simply
trying to figure out where to quit this
bishop
but again to be fair the time control of
this game
was not exactly um the way
that one would try to you know do his
best to win
well let me rephrase that do the most
precise
moves to win thank you
thank you this for you super nice of you
all right so there's a i want to get to
that cool end game position so i'm gonna
skip through a few moves
um white is simply developing and trying
to find the best way to
poke around some of these weaknesses um
i found the h5 move a little weird but
i am not um
i am not exactly sure like i wish i had
a nice to put somewhere on g6
but i understand the idea of it try like
you're simply trying to bring more
pressure
bring more issues um
all right so in this position blank
simply click queen e7 i'm gonna scroll
through a little bit
because these are just normal moves
developments getting my pieces in a
better places
poking around a little eating some ponds
doing a little sacrificing but the
points that the position that i want to
get
at is about 10 moves away from this
position
so i'm going to take another quick break
and ask you guys
what should we do so
just as an evaluation we're not trying
to
find the best moves because we don't
have the time for it
also also um we
as long as we know how is the position
and what are we playing for
and which side are we playing and as
long as we have a feeling for the
position
it's easier to find the moves
so what should what do you think white
should do
okay thank you i'm manny that was fast
yeah well
the easiest way is what does my
opponents want my palm yeah no you ain't
eating my pawn
so just b3 rick c7
now opponents trying to create some
funny stuff on c file
bye bye i'm not gonna let you do that
rook c6
now again bishop ichi this bishop
youtube was played again
and again so it's a little funny for me
um i agree why does a tad bit better
its dynamic equality could no i think
white's better
because you see there is one bishop and
two pawns in exchange for a drug but
these are two bishops
and these two bishops are just monsters
look
the rip moves bam i come again attack
the other one it's like the attack never
ends
um in the game black simply played king
h8
and white was super chill or kf1 just
gonna develop make my work in a better
position
i'm just gonna keep my king in a better
position i thought king h2 was worth
noticing as well
but came nothing wrong with king g2 rook
d7
boomer 2 just waiting waiting to see
what you want to play
and again there were a lot of instances
that
white could have played better uh black
would have been more accurate
but uh it doesn't mean that they're not
good moves it's just
i don't necessarily love the idea of
rookie 2
but i understand it's the pressure on e4
i want to defend it
why not take e6 i want to but there's a
bishop here
um oh why not take e6 right away here
well if you took on e6
um what if take
take take on g3
it's a little concerning could be
interesting
could just be kingish one and nothing
else comes out of it too
but the thing is like you can't really
take this guy because your e1 falls
uh if you want to be more precise we can
also think about
kind of like the idea of rookie
the bishop d5 now just
i can't do this bishop e4 anymore
oh wait actually
ah thank you mayor that for the
donation super nice of you
now um i think the biggest thing about
not playing bishop v6 is that the time
control of
this um game because i believe it was an
armageddon
you can't just do whatever you want you
actually have to be very
um very smart about it you can't just
take left and right you have to see does
this give my opponent this opportunity
because if it gives opportunity then we
probably
should not so bishop v6 is worth
considering i agree
but so is rook f1 okay everyone just
keeps things a little bit
more together
so all right let's say we got to
this rookie two all right this uh
nope here yes sorry a little bit longer
i apologize
ah where is my end game that's about
four more moves away i should have
started from there
ah man okay so
um this was the position i wanted to
mention
another point so in the game white made
a small inaccuracy of playing queen g4
when the move d5 would have been the
best because if take
take and that these two bishops are
going to be big monsters
hello king hello king d6 coming up
queen h6 is another threat so that's
another thing to keep in mind either as
i played queen to g4
um followed by bishop c3 again you see a
lot of these moves are just waiting
rules
waiting to see where will my opponent
mess up
uh after queen c6 bishop a5
now white has clear advantage these two
pawns are going to be baby queens as
well
[Music]
and in the game in this position
was another part that was super cool
okay
i'm going to take a second ask you guys
what do you think why should do in this
position there are like three or four
more moves left actually
uh yeah three or four more moves left on
the position so let's try our best what
do you think white should do
keep in mind that they're both in time
trouble keep in mind that
this is one of those games that you need
to win as white
i see bishop c3 push pawn on d5
i see these ideas bishops again another
bishop c3 interesting
upper psychological throw hey we need to
win it
so the fun part is
that well white could have simply played
king history and hold a huge advantage
it's so crazy i know i know it's just
the king is so safe up here nothing is
attacking it nothing is checking it it
was so funny
and i know it's really hard to see it so
if you didn't find it don't beat
yourself up
uh in the game others have played queen
g3 and after queen takes d4
bishop c3 now queen d1 was played which
was a mistake and this is where elireza
missed the win what do you think he
should have done that's our last
question of the day
after that i will be showing how the egg
game ended which is like
two more moves left okay three
but yeah so what do you think what do
you think is
white's best move
trapping the queen that would be fun i
agree but you won't be trapping the
queen
that's what i used to play drug d2 it's
the natural move there's a plated
and it was wrong
nope i'm nobody's saying it wow
i'll give you guys maybe 30 more seconds
nope not 25 25 is interesting but nope
i like the idea of queen f4 trying to go
for queen h6
but all of these have a simple problem
black can still play pawn to e5
and pawn to e5 kind of kills a lot of
white's ideas
so yes david bishop e5 thank you
that's rookie is what there's a play
bishop is what he should have played
now for c8 not even queen e1 works
this this bishop is just a tall pawn
crying over here
uh in the game erza played rook d2 queen
b1
queen f4 now this has a strong threads
rook d2 or b2 coming up
queen h6 coming up a lot of different
ways of winning
and white unfortunately uh kind of i
think
missed this idea with e5 because after
take
and take the agreed to a draw
especially because well if he didn't
take it and if he put it to bishop takes
p8
brick goes to epsilon you move the queen
bam
i take it over here bishop f4
you lose all of your pawns you lose all
of your advantage because those were
your mini baby queens
so that would be a just like a
tad bit better for white but it's quite
hopeless to try and win this
um why is bishop e5 better than queen e5
well bishop e5 stops all the e5s if you
were to play queen to e5
let's see what is your threat are you
trying to play queen to g7 because you
can't really do that my bishop is still
right here
what would you do if let's say root
close to f8 and i want to give you
start giving you these fun checks the
problem is you don't really have rft2
anymore because not g4 faults too
queenie factorizing doesn't really have
any threat that's the problem
so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this i
know i went a little over time because
dennis is supposed to be starting
two minutes ago so i apologize for that
it was fun
and yes this was one of those games that
we never know
if there was absolute silence with
others would have won
but i believe that the the ultimate
point was even if he won he would have
less
tie break points compared to
jordan so i don't know ultimately how
much difference would have it made
but it was kind of one of those funny
things that you never think
happens in super tournaments but when it
does you get to talk about it
tell your friends about it make the
chess world sounds super
cool and all crazy and wild and
yeah well i hope you guys like this game
um
please feel free to hang around and
enjoy
your lesson with dennis he is an amazing
teacher
super sweet always smiling and he
doesn't have a cat though to my
knowledge
dennis get a cat uh but besides that
i will see you guys friday on twitch for
our usual friday five to seven central
time
uh a little bit of end game a little bit
of tactics
and with that i will say goodbye to you